hey everyone its Johanna here so Apple
or V shaped ladies this workout is for
you having an apple shape means you tend
to have a heavy upper body you carry a
lot more weight around your waistline
with a smaller lower body because you
are carrying a lot more on top you may
have a delicate ankles or knees which
means doing any high intensity workout
which involves running or jumping can
impact on your joints especially if you
are overweight to swing down you will
still need to focus on your cardio
exercises choose low impact cardio such
as swimming cycling or if you are in the
gym use the ruie stepper cross trainer
machine or walk on the treadmill on an
incline but do not hold on to the
handles kickboxing is also another great
cardio to tone up and slim down on the
upper body and it is a lot of fun I do
have a couple of kickboxing cardio
workout videos which you can follow
today's workout aim to slim down on your
upper body and car and to increase more
lean muscles into your legs and butt to
balance your body up so you will need
two pairs of dumbbells one pair of light
dumbbells between two to three kilos
each and one pair of heavy dumbbells
between eight to ten kilos each start
with a 5 to 10 minute warm-up and let's
work out together
so we will be starting with three super
sets for the upper body alternating with
one set for the lower body
so grab your lightweight dumbbell and
let's start with Ben over row and
reverse fly sir step face forward bend
your body keep your chest up right back
over row and reverse fly
so for each workout we want to be doing
15 to 20 reps okay
I'll be doing 15 reps with you today
let's go for squeeze your back me back
five this is great upper back good six
alphabet seven keep your chest up right
do not hunch eight squeeze nine good
squeeze ten really open up and squeeze
out my back
one two up good three squeeze four and
one more fun and squeeze good job
second workout get onto the floor it
will be fly with leg extension
I can't bring your dumbbells up right
I'm going to bring it down open as far
as you can bring it up and twist your
wrist all right
the unis keep your legs on the floor
intermediate bring it up let's go open
what all right - if you want to
challenge yourself even more keep your
leg straight good three so what we're
doing is working on our chest and also
your core at the same time for focus
squeeze the chest five leg straight six
good
down seven as white as you can open use
the chest eight nice my twist your wrist
ten keep your help keep your dumbbells
in line with your chest one good tight
your car two three squeeze good chest
and core at the same time for one more
five and release step back up no break
next Stu on our upper body should write
the coast with alternating shoulder
press right fifteen let's go ah choice
twist good down squeeze one two at the
same time rotate your torso to work on
your car
three up twist twist
remember to use the muscles for your
bicep for good ah five twist six toe so
take your adds seven nice eight come on
ladies
good nine keep your body upright do your
chest your biceps ten your shoulders
working get five more one twist twist to
all the way up all the way up no halfway
three last two and I want you to grab
the heavy weights to work on your lower
body twist twist good drop the weights
grab your heavier weight then bring my
knees to lift the weight up all right ah
next workout is deadlift
so stand shoulder width apart in line
okay I want you to bend from your waist
bend your knees into a slight squat
position
push off with your heels use the leg
muscles and squeeze your lower back
ready heavy weights to really focus on
proper form and give me ten dumb all the
way down chest up
up squeeze one good down to squeeze your
legs hamstrings bar know that good down
three very nice let's go build those
muscles into your like four let's count
one two three five good let's go keep
the dumbbells close your thighs six four
more one two three up seven good three
more this will be tough it's going to be
muscles into your leg eight last two
talent qhs up ride whoop one more down
down down and squeeze it up drop the
dumbbells remember been farini's not
from your lower back all right back to
upper body grab the weights now I want
you to do push ups and rotate because
you have a heavier body push ups can be
challenging so you can start on your
knees
all right go down into a push-up
position down rotate up all right that's
one down and the other side as you get
stronger you can get onto your toes to
pop twist good for nice down five times
in your core good
six up remember I do not want to see
this this is wrong
seven right rotate down eight rotate
let's try to go on to our toes there you
go not get rotate ten nice whoa this is
going to turn up on you have about in
one come on for more stay strong - good
you should really feel cold working as
well
three up let's go for aa twist and
rotate one more by ah and rotate good
job now next workout we want to work on
your shoulders which is lateral raise
with run/race all right simple are you
are really going to feel it in your
shoulders
let's go fifteen on each one up good
down control up so really control all
the way down and feel your shoulders
working - nice three squeeze slow up
slow for get up
view the bird when you showed us five
knots then shuttle with a pot 6o result
seven come on
halfway there up if you find this time
Jing you can bend your elbows slightly
eight all right bend your elbows
slightly you will get easier if you bend
your elbows nine up keep going
ten ah let's go five more
one come on strong shoulders link upper
body two down ah
three more Oh breathe out when it is
hard up last two breathe out up one more
and give me ten one two three four five
six seven hold eight nine sent down you
know what's nice ah
one two five eight three four five six
seven eight nine ten good job
drop the weights I want you to get into
dips
alright if you can use a higher platform
for instance you can even use this okay
so step forward and dig all the way down
and bring your body up if this is too
easy one foot up all right let's go use
a high platform to make it even more
challenging small dicks - I want you to
give me twenty four days three four five
six seven eight
keep going nine ten ten more one two
three four five six seven
eight nine ten all right good to make it
more challenging next time you can even
put some weight on your thighs
then you will increase the intensity or
increase the platform lower body
grab your heavy dumbbells again prime
for your knees lift it up I want you to
perform lunges right let's get into a
lunge position let's start with our
right side to begin with okay so step
forward lunge down slightly too forward
to increase intensity and step back okay
so ten times on your right side let's go
step forward lunge down slightly push
back good one down same leg
- nice tighten your core use your legs
three nice down to four whoop
these will really challenge your core
down five good five more one ah let's go
to two up last three three to four push
two more one push and last one down and
two good change leg ready left side
let's go down sealed push it back good
really use the power from your legs to
push it back
- nice three push good when your balance
for keep going
that's your five to buy more halfway
there
six oh good
even I'm struggling seven to nine three
eight tilt last to nine come on ladies
one more last one ten till whoa let's no
drop the weight okay gently drop the
weight and we need to work on your core
ah you might not like this but we want
to be doing playing up down because it
really works on your upper body and your
core at the same time to really trim
those heavy tops so give me 15 playing
up down get ready
down let's go one up that's one to
tighten your core three nuts for
straight body if you find is difficult
again five you can stop on your knees
six seven all right the other side eight
good nine
then nice one plague can be challenging
for beginners too but it is the best
call workout three last two for last one
five down and now grab your lightweight
we want to be doing crunch and reach all
have your upper body
and when you use the weight to leave
yourself up so down onto the floor you
can choose the better knees or keep your
legs straight
leave your dumbbells up I wanted to
punch up and reach
okay let's go 20 of those one easier
version
I know nice to really reach all the way
up good three nice keep going for
breathe out on the way up
five six I promise you this is the last
workout and you will get a break seven
nice 8 on your toes good
nice you will feel your shoulders
working as well so I'm really torturing
your upper body and your core to burn
calories nice - eight more three breathe
out reach four as it gets easier lift
heavier weight five reach give it
control down six so do not collapse
control seven control eight control down
nine oh one more ten and Jonas you drop
the weight shake everything out and you
can relax and stretch for one minute
before you move on to your second round
this is a very good stretching posture
to stretch the entire body out like this
video if you are sweating like me in
just about 15 minutes I've burned an
average of 130 calories based on my
height and my weight for best result do
this workout three times weekly on
alternate days then do your cardio
exercises three to four times weekly for
at least 40 minutes on the other days
beginners do two sets intermediate three
sets
advance four sets this strength training
will not only help you burn calories
it will also minimize fat accumulation
all the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you
you